hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the full release of among
the sleep now this game you guys have
been waiting for and i've been waiting
for for quite a while
if you don't remember it's where you're
a baby and you try to get through your
house at night when dastardly demons are
knocking at your door
there was another game called baby blues
that was kind of the same theme but i
bet this one came first before it i
think it actually did the idea
of a child being thrown into the
situation of death and destruction and
horror
was originally come came up by these
guys what is happening
why is a baby having an lsd trip am i in
an alien spaceship what the hell is
oh i'm drinking a bottle oh god that was
so weird i don't know why i didn't
notice that
did you finish your drink already yes
mama
oh god i'm throwing a tantrum it might
break
it was disgusting thanks mom now it'll
only be a minute
mommy just has to make sure that the
cake is perfect
is it my birthday thanks mom i'm gonna
do some abacus mathematics
i'm so smart are you proud of me are you
proud of your boy
maybe i'm a girl i don't know
there and there thanks
i love you so much mama oh
look at me you're so adorable in your
tiny footed pajamas
thank you
happy birthday sweetie oh that animation
is really good
wow two years today two years i know
you're off by 22 but that's okay i think
i know a little somewhere
for some cake ah put it on my mouth
chugga chugga chugga chugga choo
choos
thanks mom here we go
oh uh
excuse me i'll be
right back uh okay thanks mom that was
weird
okay oh
all right gonna do some abacusing
kid is not having a fun time what did
you put in that cake lady
lady no
okay so i'm guessing that was the
the dad the divorce dead look what i
found
i wonder what it is it's a present why
don't we go upstairs and find out
okay thanks mom who's at the door
oh my how much cake did you have
you only fed me two spoonfuls you didn't
give me enough i'm i'm actually quite
hungry
okay this is this is kind of weird hi
hello there well aren't you high yes
oh yay
i am too i could walk lady but that oh
how pretty
krill bites studio wait a minute what is
that mom look out
that's a black ooze it's the news of
black mom
mama mommy
mommy mama mom mom
mama presents this is a very well do
okay
this is one messed up kid here if this
is all that he's seeing
among the sleep oh i'm so ready for this
i was i was really hoping that this was
gonna be a really good experience and it
looks like
they put just a ton of work into it and
i appreciate that
very much so unless they just threw all
their budget into the first intro
sequence and then they have
nothing else to show for it but i highly
doubt that hi
now let's see what's inside we're just
gonna ignore that darkness
i'm ready
oh i love it oh okay sweetie
be a dear and play for a bit mommy will
be right back wait a minute no my
present i saw what it was can i have it
oh you're going to leave me in here with
the eye
okay thanks mom from my perspective you
look very creepy
but i love you because you're my mother
goodbye i gotta get out of here
i gotta break out of folsom prison i
need to get my beer
something happening over there but i
don't much appreciate it excuse me
this little tunnel i can crawl through
okay that was fun
glad i did that why is crawling faster
oh yeah cause i'm a little baby
oh okay and yup and away we go
okay thanks kid you can stop breathing
so much
okay so need to open the drawers i
remember this from the demo that i
played the demo was actually
almost a year ago now uh i need to move
that just a little bit so i can climb up
maybe we'll just climb up okay that'll
work get out of here
uh dumpy the elephant i need to get my
present
bear what the wait a minute wasn't there
a teddy bear in here
i kind of want to say that there was a
teddy bear in there
where did he go where'd my teddy bear go
well that can't be right what the hell
happened
no now did i break the game already
there was a teddy bear in there i know
there was what does this do
but something not right there was a
teddy bear in the box
i'm not crazy i just started playing
this game i'm not crazy yet
hi i see your beady little black eyes
hey you found me yeah
i sure did my name is teddy
nice to meet you hey what's your name
markiplier
markiplier not much of a talker yet hey
i'm known for talking i dog a lot let's
play a game
i yell a lot too i'm very loud people
are no okay uh okay hi
okay i'll get out of your way i'll hide
the pink elephant while you're not
looking
okay teddy you got it bro i'm totally
down with that you are a cool dude and i
like the way you think
turn around and cover your eyes you got
it bro
ready how do i cover my eyes
are my eyes covered yet why am i poking
my belly button stop poking your belly
button there buddy
there's nothing interesting in there how
do i cover my eye okay
uh i'm not looking
i swear i'm okay all right um
how do i cover my eyes i don't know how
to cover my eyes you didn't give me any
information
what am i supposed to do there little
buddy go in the corner maybe
stare in the corner until everything
goes away so the darkness comes to claim
my soul
what oh oh
what there you can look now okay that
was weird
that is a very weird mechanic but thank
you i found him
it wasn't very hard that was where i was
you found it i did aren't i aren't i
great i'm very smart i
came through accelerated fourth grade i
am incredi i was in advanced
algebra music box does it work no yes i
don't know
i'm two what do you expect me to know
let me go find for you buddy my friend
it works that's a nice
melody it is isn't it it's beautiful
it's the most beautiful melody i've ever
heard in my life
and you are probably unintentionally
creepy
so what now little buddy what do you
want to do now
i'm here to help you friend
okay fine be like that i don't know what
you want from me
oh we just got linked it oh i guess the
melody's over now
so now we get to go over and do
something else little teddy
teddy bear oh you would like to read a
book
it's a book it tells a story
this one just so happens to tell about
five thirsty animals
upon a dry dry hill i was gonna say that
we could use a drink they sang and
started to drill
wait what how did they know how to once
we reach
water with our newly dug well
i think we'll have to bid each other
fairly well
oh i think that means death it's not a
very happy book
pretty sure they're gonna die of
thorough hey hey there buddy
uh what do you want me to do with that
is through an easter egg if i spell out
something with the blocks oh yes
you wanna see it goes woo-woo you wanna
see it go woo-woo
woo-woo run how do you start it you're
staring right at it buddy i don't
i want to question your intelligence a
little bit
round and round and round yeah round and
round and round
so uh so what about that so what are you
gonna do about that
hey pick me up and carry me on your back
i wanna show you something sure you're
gonna strangle me from around the neck
i need some place very dark i don't
think i would then uh how about the
closet that looks like a good spot
out you're closing hey we think so alike
can i bowl oh i fell
ah i got it i'm so good at games
hey i got an achievement too look at me
look at me big man achievement man
what's in my closet besides darkness and
death
has to be darker shut the doors
completely why do i want that what kind
of teddy are you
good this will do nicely no
bad i hope there are no monsters in here
why would you say that
that's exactly what you don't say like i
hope i don't get murdered
feel scared in a dark place like this
you can hug me tightly
you might feel a little bit safer no
i'm hugging you oh i get it but why
is this hair
why is this a thing okay
hi oh things look so weird from a
child's perspective
but i guess that's the intention we must
be careful
i don't like this yeah you told me to
come back here why would you want me to
if you don't like it
oh the big tall robes don't mean well
is that blood on the walls was that
moving
that is actually quite disturbing i do
not like that
please do not bother me big
shut the hell up you douche i don't want
anything to do with you
yes maybe if i talk louder than the
noises of the monsters they won't bother
i mean me bay
oh god i wasn't scared of you the teddy
bear just appeared
does it oh are you
playing with your new friend yeah hello
mr bear
my name is teddy nice to meet you how
are you today
you've got to stop hiding from mommy
i'll try not to
do it you had a good birthday hun um
mommy would be very sad if you didn't
okay
um now it's time for bed that was a hole
in that closet
if you go to sleep now you can wake up
early tomorrow
and play with your friend every day
but what if also i have nightmares what
if also
the darkness claims me every little boy
and girl are sleeping now
all over the world and they're waiting
just for you
we shouldn't keep them not reassuring
not reassuring in any way
anyway shape or form
good night
okay all right i like this
i don't know why this seems so creepy to
me it should just be a normal loving
family but in a way it's awfully
disturbing
oh god i am in nightmare world i was
just waiting for the moment when i would
awaken
in this diabolical day in this world of
which i will never return
to the normal one because i die of death
did that even make any sense to you guys
i don't know if it did but at least i
got my teddy bear here
i don't know why my teddy bear is slap
okay
i i literally just said at least i have
a teddy bear here and it's being dragged
away from me
i don't like that i do not like that
very much
hey this is very paranormal activity
one-ish
hello
how about you open your eyes
hi
what is that what is happening
okay thanks
why why would you do this to a little
child
why does a child need to be tormented as
such
i thought i pulled that over oh it's
raining and it's at night
how delightful i wonder if there's still
monsters in here
monsters anybody
okay so the hole in my closet seems to
have disappeared
hello i gotta admit this is
exceptionally creepy
just disturbingly creepy i mean it's
excessively compounded because i am a
child
and i'm imagining all this oh if you
need to peek around corners
why would i need to do that perhaps
there is a monster over there
perhaps there is some diamond looking
demon that wants to eat my swole
my little tiny children hand
what was that thing that dwight fruit
once saying oh
go to sleep something or you'll be
eating i don't know
i don't remember it's dwight schrute
from the office how how am i supposed to
remember
that's not a good sound
no somebody's screaming in pain
that's definitely not advantageous i
think this is actually where the
oh okay this is where the demo picked up
uh that's locked so i need to go find a
key for that
ah that's right
ah i got you
thank you
something's not right
uh-huh we need to find
your mother no kidding it's not a good
thing
i'm gonna hold you tight to my chest so
i got some illumination
also your uh moistness is awfully
comforting to me
a small child
cool i think i remember that we need to
go find my madre
because some bad juju is going off in
this place
i don't remember being very quiet before
is anybody there mr floppy bunders
hello why do we have so many giant coats
seems awfully excessive for one
household
gonna crawl down
hello oh i remember this hello mr
lightning i remember this
okay so if i recall some bad stuff
hi thank you i remember i thought i was
in the bedroom for a second there
no thank you mama some uh
something's haunted this place can you
do something about that
or not it's fine whatever my little
child heart is beating very quickly but
that's normal that's normal
young people's heart rates are on
average higher than
adults what the hell is that sound
sounds like someone's dragging metal
around somewhere okay
i'm gonna take you you're gonna help me
unlock this doodad
i'm gonna move on then i'm gonna move on
and you're never gonna see me ever again
no not what i wanted to do yeah that's
what i wanted to do
i heard something didn't like it
like what i heard okay why do we have so
many coats
why so many tall raincoats it's
illogical that one even
even has shoes on it what does that
sound
mom who do that why is that down here
hello
hello there's an awfully big crack in
the wall
did someone punch that why also why
not like this shut up okay thank you
this is the bedroom right this is the
bedroom something happened in the
bedroom
okay this is not what i recall the
office
so
okay there's these sounds
don't make any sense can i get up there
probably could if i really wanted to
maybe i don't need to
where am i i don't remember any of this
it's all very different or maybe it's
exactly the same and i'm just an
idiot but i don't remember any of this
yep
thank you get up up up up up up up up
all right go okay now i need to extend
that out
that like that update
thank you now this is the bedroom okay
oh
i thought that was a face for a second
there mama
am i even though i know you're not
actually here
mama mama whoa
what
it's always appropriate to face your
dangers head on
hi
nothing you're not brave enough to face
a two-year-old boy and 24 year old man
boy controlling that little boy
someone singing over here got another
freaking coat it's getting close to
where the demo
ended the demo is great by the way i
can't wait i can't wait to see what more
there is for this game
i'm gonna go through here
okay fine then
if that's how you're gonna be
why do i hear sing okay guys
sorry forgot about that was that a thing
that happened before i don't remember
okay fell again that's okay i'm gonna
cry like a little baby hello
this is important it was glowing or
maybe it's just in the moonlight
mama mama mama mom
mom mom
what are you doing in there mom
what the hell is that what the hell is
that
do i remember this why do i not remember
any of the oh my
something is happening i don't know
i'm a little kid how would i know a
little kid has an imagination like this
no it's hard but
it it seems more like
a memory yeah
oh
a memory a memory thing thingy
hello mama are you down here
you want to say something to me mama
mama
okay little kid falling down a tube
totally okay not gonna get hurt in any
way
hello are you all right pretty much
only scarred for life that's okay all
right so there's reached about oh hello
whoa what is this place i don't know you
tell me
you're probably more knowledgeable than
i am and i'm gonna find out that you're
actually evil
and you caused all this so anyway this
is where i'm gonna end it here so that i
can keep playing
expect more of this very very soon so
anyway thank you all so much for
watching click the annotation for more
videos that i've done
and as always i will see you in the next
video
bye-bye please hey
there are people still in here
what are you talking about this place is
supposed to be abandoned question mark
i thought this place was abandoned